ah
[Aplausos]
quiero que se imaginen una montaña
no más alta todavía
mucho mucho más sal
desde donde la ven
yo desde la cima
si hoy estoy viviendo el presente que
siempre soñé
pero como dice fito páez lo importante
no es llegar lo importante es el camino
y ya se van a dar cuenta por qué
nací en una familia rodeada de
voluntarios en mi casa ayudar a alguien
es algo habitual y es por eso que yo no
logró concebir mi vida sin estar para
que lo necesita
pero hablando de familia claro está que
para ellos no ha sido nada fácil cuando
se enteraron de que yo iba a nacer con
discapacidad
la sociedad no te prepara para eso
y el ácido fólico hace 31 años no tenía
la fama que tiene ahora
sin embargo
a pesar de las miles de opciones que
tenían mis padres
a mí ellos me dieron la oportunidad de
vivir
y eso no es poca cosa
ellos
ese 13 de junio del 90
me pararon al pie de la montaña
empecé a transitar mis primeros pasos
primero con andador
luego con bastones
llevando conmigo una mochila
esa mochila típica con la que cargamos
las personas con discapacidad que
dependiendo del contexto podemos estar
allá abajo como los marginados los
pobrecitos los castigados por la vida
guay arriba como los superhéroes los que
vienen al mundo con un mensaje revelador
y que pueden con todos
marginados
versos superhéroes
parece que la discapacidad no hay punto
medio
recuerdo incluso una vez que se me
acerca una persona me toca el hombro con
una actitud de consuelo y me dice
querida yo sos un ser de luz para el
mundo
ser de luz
tengo cara de focos
continué mi camino
y en ese camino me iba encontrando con
distintas piedras
piedras que representaban historias
marginados versos superhéroes pero al
mismo tiempo viene encontrando con
distintos símbolos símbolos que
representaban cada una de las
oportunidades que me dio la vida de
hacer voluntariado
el primero de ellos fue un dragón un
dragón en silla de ruedas
en esta organización yo descubrí lo que
era la libertad
descubrí lo que realmente quería hacer
descubrir incluso que tenía esta actitud
de líder
y lo más lindo fue descubrir que
podía defender mis propios derechos sin
esperar que otro lo haga por mí
el primer desafío grande que tuve que
enfrentar fue ir a dar una nota a la
televisión local para contar lo que era
la organización
días posteriores es la fila del super
una señora médica mirando y me dice vos
sos la que dio una nota el otro día no
les juro que me sentí angelina jolie
entrando por primera vez a los estudios
de hollywood
si era eso
qué bueno qué bueno que te animaste a
salir así a pesar de todo
pensé que fue re mal vestida me muero de
la vergüenza pero tome coraje y se lo
pregunte
y saben que la señora no me respondió
agachó la cabeza dio media vuelta y se
fue
él me di cuenta que esto
no era la ropa
esa fue
la primera piedra grande con la que me
encontré
la tomé y la guardo en mi mochila
seguí avanzando por mi camino y esta
mochila se iba haciendo cada vez más y
más y más pesada se iba llenando cada
vez de más piedras de todos los tamaños
colores y formas que ustedes se puedan
imaginar
y llegó un momento
en el que ya no podía más
en el que esa mochila
ya pesaba demasiado
y quise dejar todo
quise dejar incluso que esa mochila sea
la protagonista de mi vida
y rendirme
y ahí es donde como digo siempre
sucederá magia
me encontré el segundo símbolo
esta vez no era un riego
era una rueda
9 de 24 dientes
en esta organización
me descubrí
supe realmente todo lo que yo tenía
dentro todo lo que tenía para dar e
incluso cosas que ni yo me imaginaba
conocí muchísimas personas viajé
inclusive fuera del país algo que en mi
vida me hubiese imaginado a lograr
crecí personalmente a pasos agigantados
pero lo más lindo
fue haber tenido la oportunidad
y ayudar a otros a crecer
no saben lo lindo que es lo lindo que se
siente cuando uno se da cuenta que puedo
aportar aunque sea un pequeño granito de
arena para ayudar a los otros
para ayudar a otros a llegar a su cima
escalar su montaña
es una sensación inexplicable pero que
se las recomiendo
aun asi
la mochila estaba las piedras no se iban
sino que seguían apareciendo
un fin de semana me tocó viajar a carlos
paz a un evento de capacitación
y entre las personas que conocí me
encontré con un cordobés
que se me acerca y me dice y vos qué
haces acá
por qué porque voluntaria si vos tenés
discapacidad nosotros ayudamos a las
personas como vos
tú están de este lado
yo les garantizo
que en mis casi 30 años en ese momento
no había escuchado palabras tan fuertes
como esas
dolieron en el alma
fue un momento en el que no sabía si
llorar si enojarme si irme si
responderles y callarme era un sinfín de
emociones
estaba sin dudas frente a la piedra más
grande que había visto en mi vida
y esas piedras que no las puedes correr
no las puedes empujar no las puedes
patear están ahí
tienes que enfrentarlos otra no queda
saben qué pasó
la sal de
si gente la salte con esto que ven las
artes
porque en ese momento por encima de esa
piedra apareció mágicamente un acuerdo
esa cuerda de la que me amarre fuerte
sin dudarlo y llega al otro lado
y cuando llegue al otro lado descubrí
que haya sido amarrada por cada una de
las personas que siempre confiaron en mí
esas personas que siempre estuvieron ahí
que siempre me animaron a hacer cada una
de las cosas que siempre quise hacer
esas personas que en cada una de las
locuras que quise hacer en mi vida me
acompañaron siempre
esas personas que inclusive cuando les
dije sabes que mandarte para una chava
te de c's
me miraron y me dicen es una locura
pero te acompaño igual
bueno ellos fueron los que tiraron la
cuerda
y pensar que todavía hay gente que me
preguntas por qué dedico tanto tiempo de
mi vida a ser voluntariado
y lo que no
y vos
qué estás esperando
qué estás esperando para saltar tus
propias piedras
porque yo sé que las tienes todos las
tenemos
qué estás esperando incluso
para tirar vos la cuerda para que otro
pueda saltar sus propias piedras
porque sabes que todos podemos saltar
las porque todos tenemos personas del
otro lado capaces de tirarnos la cuerda
para que lo podamos hacer
porque sabían que no estamos solos en el
mundo
sabían que hay gente que siempre está
ahí que aunque se en el silencio siempre
está y que son capaces de tirar esa
cuerda en el momento que sea que lo
necesitemos
dale anímate
anímate
yo sé que puedes
ahora yo les pregunto
desde qué lugar es la higiene ustedes
ver su propia montaña
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]